APPENDICITIS IN AUGUST, HE SAT
KIND OF A STOP-START BEGINNING E
NATION
COUNTERATTACK
KINGS.
TURNOVER BY THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS,
LIAS ANDERSSON CARRIES IT OUT,
E
WHWH KOPITAR
UPENDED, THEODORE PUCK.
FROM THAT  HARD.
YOU CAN SEE HOW QUICKLY THE
GOLDEN KNIGHTS CAN CREATE A
LOOSE PUCK AND MAKE SOMETHING
>> Alex: 26 SECONDS APART, IS
THEREFORE THE SWEDE.
AS IS A BROKEN PLAY.
KEMPE FOR IAFALLO.BLE EVERY SINE
CHCH A MODIFIER EXPECTED
GOAL CHANCES, BUT THEY
CHIP AND CHASE, FORECHECKS GOAL.
WATCH WHAT UP INITIALLY ON
PACIORETTY, LOOKS LIKE HE'S
OKAY, TRI
WOLANIN AROUND THE BOARDS.
AS
THEY COULD BE ON THE CLEARING
ATTEMPTS.
THIS T T PUCK TO AN AREA.
MAKING ITE.
KOPITAR FANS, IMPLORING THE
KINGSLICIT TO NEUTRAL ICE BEHIND
KARLSSON. MAY HAVE
HAD A PIECE OF IT.
THIS CLEAR GETS A
TONIGHT, AND KINGS LEAD ARE
LOSES HIS STICK AND STICK OF
THEODORE.
PACIORETTY.
PERIOD.
THEY TRIED A COUPLE TIMES TO THH
MARCHESSAULT, NUMBERS FOR VEGAS.
MARCHESSAULT TO KARLSSON RIGHT ,